we have an in case you missed it where
the 95 meets the 215 northern beltway
come on let's go
centennial bowling
okay so the last of the freeway to free
over flyover connections is the one
that's going to take south on 95 drivers
to the eastbound 215 northern beltway
so while work on that connector is
probably going to be finished before the
end of the year
the nevada department of transportation
is now saying they're going to hold off
on
opening that connector until july of
next year
that's when all of the other work in the
centennial bowl is scheduled to wrap
up so i'm keeping this map up on our
website because it spells out all the
little pieces parts of the other rams
and connectors
uh the new exits even a multi-use trail
and it is worth checking out
so here's the deal you can check it all
out on eight newsnow.com click traffic
and then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if something's driving you crazy email
me traffic 8 8 news now dot com